je ne suis pas élève donc c'était une
élection interne alors cioti est sorti
il a pas il a fait un score
53,15 donc c'est pas mal mais
ça veut dire qu'il y a deux courants
très fort au sein des LR et Bodo
Retailleau que je connais bien que je
côtoie au quotidien a fait aussi une
très belle campagne moi ce qui m'importe
aujourd'hui c'est pas de savoir qui est
président qui qui est président DLR est
c'est ce surtout qui va rassembler qui
va rassembler parce que moi je ne crois
que aujourd'hui au rassemblement
d'ailleurs on a toujours gagné dans le
rassemblement dans les périodes
anciennes le RP et l'UDF était ensemble
quand on voulait gagner ça a été pareil
aussi dans des élections départementales
régionales voire locale donc moi je ne
crois qu'au rassemblement et aujourd'hui
c'est pas parce que la tête d'un parti
que on va réussir la seule réussite pour
moi ça sera la personne qui aura un vrai
projet et qui sera capable de rassembler
je vous rappelle aussi que il y une
autre élection dans un parti centriste
c'est Hervé Marseille donc le président
du groupe 1h sont triste dans lequel je
siège au Sénat qui a été élu président
de l'UDI je connais Hervé lui aussi il
est pour le rassemblement dont j'attends
le rassemblement